un pronunciamiento esperado del
presidente sirio bachar alazad a mamá
esta cumbre de la liga árabe es una
oportunidad histórica para abordar
cuestiones regionales sin interferencia
extranjera
luego de 12 años de guerra el presidente
sirio reaparece en la escena
internacional en este restaurante la
capital Siria Damasco Gibrán estudiante
universitario atiende por televisión el
discurso de asad en la liga árabe
cualquier regreso al redil internacional
creará apertura estoy seguro de que esto
creará un entorno que conduzca al
retorno en las inversiones al
levantamiento de las sanciones
pero el optimismo no es compartido en el
norte del país epicentro de la guerra
que ha sufrido el paso el autoproclamado
estado islámico y los combates entre el
ejército sirio y grupos Rebeldes a
Damasco
ciudad cercana a la región Deep donde
vaya a echar a la Sad es acusado de
haber utilizado armas químicas contra la
población civil Víctimas de la violencia
protestan contra huáscar mientras que
ondean la bandera de la principal
guerrilla del país el ejército libre
sirio
hoy como ciudadana Siria que vive en las
áreas liberadas me revelo contra este
régimen que me ha hecho sufrir el dolor
de la detención el asedio y el
desplazamiento
tenemos 15 prisioneros en nuestra
familia y 100 Mártires hacemos un
llamado a los pueblos árabes para que
presionen a sus gobiernos y pidan la
renuncia de bajar para que sea juzgado
con más de 300.000 muertos y una de las
peores crisis de refugiados de las
últimas décadas la permanencia de asad
en el poder es un recuerdo vivo de la
guerra